[Musique]
dans l'actualité de ce lundi 4 avril
c'est le rendez vous annuel de
l'innovation le pari c'est avec l'esprit
n'y reviens les 12 et 13 mai prochains
l'événement proposera conférence rendez
vous d'affaires et rencontre entre pme
laboratoires de recherche ou encore
grand groupe sky therapeutics sera de la
partie elle utilise la biotechnologie un
des secteurs innovants du territoire
organisée par l'assurance maladie à
destination des 18-25 ans les skins game
sorte et amélie de la a pris place pour
la première fois sur le territoire
vendredi 1er avril elle la cpam a
organisé huit sessions à la maison de
l'étudiant de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines au programme
prévention et information
et puis les ont lancé leur activité
professionnelle via les réseaux sociaux
pour ce nouveau dossier de la semaine la
rédaction s'est penchée sur les
influenceurs yvelinois le premier volet
consacré à nina à diététicienne à son
compte depuis deux ans
[Musique]
c'est une start up à la pointe de la
biotechnologie sky thérapeutique se
développent un traitement pour la
myopathie de duchenne une dégénération
des muscles chez l'homme une entreprise
créée en 2015 est incubé à la faculté de
médecine de l'université versailles
saint quentin et les recherches
commencent à aboutir
l'avancée majeure c'est d'avoir mis au
point une molécule
donc un médicament potentiellement
pour traiter cette maladie qui est
difficile à traiter parce qu'elles
touchent tout le corps il faut il faut
pouvoir atteindre tout le corps donc ça
c'est particulièrement complexe à
l'origine de cette start-up plusieurs
associations de parents d'enfants
atteints de la myopathie de duchenne à
leurs côtés le docteur luis garcia
directeur de recherche au cnrs il
travaille depuis une vingtaine d'années
sur ce sujet j'ai commencé par faire de
la thérapie génique ya une quinzaine
d'années matane d'année et puis en
parallèle de cette thérapie génique on a
travaillé avec des chimistes au fil du
temps les en comparant l'efficacité on
s'est rendu compte que la solution
chimique n'étaient pas aussi mauvaises
qu'on qu'on pouvait l'anticiper et
qu'elle même elle est très prometteuse
et nous avons développé cette date
jusqu'à aujourd'hui est en mesure de
proposer un essai clinique dans les mois
qui viennent les essais devraient
commencer à l'automne 2022
l'aboutissement d'un long travail de
recherche devenu concret avec la
création de sky therapeutics un exemple
dans la filière de la biotechnologie sur
le territoire de paris saclay la filière
santé à paris saclay c'est à peu près
40% des start up qui naissent et qui s'y
développent donc voilà elle elle
illustre bien aussi cette excellence sur
l'industrie santé biotechnologies et
puis elle est incubé hébergés ici au
sein de l'ufr simone veil qui a la
faculté de médecine de l'hiver est ce qu
est donc de l'université paris saclay
donc voilà c'est une très belle
illustration du parcours d'une
entreprise qui n'est ici qui se
développe ici dans un no 47 lieu
d'innovation et plusieurs lieux
d'innovation du pôle paris saclay seront
à découvrir le 12 et 13 mai prochain
durant l'événement spring paris saclay
[Musique]
un premier salon du livre a pris place
ce week end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines thème de cette
première édition les visionnaires
objectif mettre en lumière près de 90
auteurs des ces deux fictions de romans
jeunesse & young adult qui interroge le
monde de demain l'événement a permis de
décerner un prix littéraire c'est
l'auteur canadien michael cristicchi
obtenu la récompense pour son livre
lorsque le dernier arbre l'événement
continue en ligne jusqu'au 8 avril plus
d'informations sur saint quentin en
yvelines point fr retour également sur
ce premier salon du livre de saint
quentin en yvelines demain dans votre
magazine culturel avec une émission
spéciale consacrée à l'événement
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça fait 10 ans
l'entrepreneuriat quand on travaille
dans
un label roberts est à la tête de son
entreprise une bibliothèque de formation
depuis dix ans ce matin cette canadienne
n'échange pas et ses collaborateurs ou
des futurs clients l'audience une classe
de terminale stg pour moi on peut pas
apprendre sans échouer et donc en france
on n'a ni le droit d'échouer neil doit
de réussir non plus parce que si on a
réussi et on gagne beaucoup d'argent il
faut le cacher il faut pas en parler
donc pour moi c'est important que ces
gens entend et voit quelqu'un qui a fait
un parcours atypique qui n'a pas fait
une grande école mais qui a quand même
pu réussir sur un chemin parallèle
annabelle roberts participe au semaine
de sensibilisation des jeunes à
l'entrepreneuriat c'est la troisième
année que l'établissement saint cyrien
accueille un professionnel sortir du
court mais en restant dans nos locaux
parce que nous élèves aiment bien être
rassurés et dans une zone de confort
qu'ils connaissent mais les faire partir
en restant ici en fait et leur des
couleurs faire découvrir que à côté de
chez eux il ya des millions de personnes
qui ont des talents et qu'il faut les
rencontrer pour qu'ils puissent eux
aussi en développer ça nous a appris
beaucoup de choses comment entreprendre
à avoir confiance en nous et c'est une
très bonne intervenante parce que elle
nous a partagé beaucoup de choses comme
à l'entreprise sans avoir peur j'ai
appris plein de choses au début je vais
faire travailler pour l'empattement mais
je pense que j'avais failli
entrepreneuriat parce qu'elle est je
pense que c'est lui qui me plaît en 2021
un peu moins d'un tiers des entreprises
en france ont été créées par des femmes
un chiffre stable depuis 2000 19
[Musique]
l'assurance maladie des yvelines lance
son tout premier escape game pour les
jeunes vendredi 1er avril une première
édition était organisée à la maison de
l'étudiant de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines l'objectif est
dé amelia se souvenir de ce qu'elle a
fait la veille 1 soirée
cet esclave gamme est composée en deux
zones une première zone sera consacré à
toutes les questions sur le jeu nature
et social à quoi sert d'assurance
maladie et à quoi sert ma carte vitale
les taux de remboursement et à la fin de
ce premier parcours ils auront une clé
pour accéder à une deuxième zone qui
sera la zone prévention
[Musique]
dans cette deuxième zone les étudiants
doivent résoudre des énigmes et des
codes pour remonter le moral d'amélie
celle ci a fait une soirée avec beaucoup
d'excès la veille et elle ne se souvient
plus si elle a consommé de la drogue ou
si elle a eu un rapport sexuel protéger
monsieur la coque
au total ils ont quinze minutes pour
trouver cinq énigmes sur la drogue les
maladies sexuellement transmissibles le
tabac ou encore le cannabis c'était
intéressant parce que ça ne va pas me
badd apprendre un peu plus sur certains
sujets qu'on connaissait pas forcément
franchement super c'est très bien j'ai
appris plein de choses intéressantes
telles que même les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles faut que
c'est génial on devrait aussi passer ça
nous apprend alors les 16 25 ans pour
nous c'est une cible très difficile à
aborder et là ça nous rend un peu plus
attractif on peut aborder ces sujets qui
ne peuvent paraître assez lourd au
quotidien à aborder et ça va nous
permettre de mieux les accompagner et
mieux les sensibiliser
susan eng un petit peu ludique mais tout
en passant non messages de prévention et
en les mettant en lien avec les
structures qui peuvent les aider
accompagner après alan est effectivement
à la fin de l'escale game de nombreux
partenaires étaient présents pour
répondre aux questions des étudiants sur
la santé sexuelle ou les addictions
d'une durée de 30 minutes environ est
entièrement gratuit il s'agissait d'une
première édition mais l'assurance
maladie des îles et n'exclut pas de
réitérer l'expérience dans les prochains
mois
[Musique]
les protéines servent entre autres à
reconstituer la fibre musculaire
influence euse de 23 ans ni la dispose
d'une communauté de onze mille abonnés
cette diététicienne à son compte depuis
deux ans et spécialisé en nutrition du
sport elle propose des consultations en
présentiel et en visioconférence son
objectif accompagner les gens vers de
meilleures habitudes alimentaires c'est
une branche qui est dans le paramédical
donc il dans l'antre elle le partage est
mal côté humain en fait on apprend en
fait les bases d'une alimentation en
jean et finalement avec la société
actuelle on a complètement perdu en fait
ces bases avec la société de
consommation alors j'ai fait une
alimentation en quatre repas par jour tu
vas voir un petit déjeuner un déjeuner
une collation et un dîner on voit
vraiment du coup l'évolution de la
personne l'accompagnement de la personne
et c'est ça qui est le plus beau en fait
voilà personne évoluer et être heureuse
en fait comblé
entre deux consultations nina s'adonne à
une toute autre activité les réseaux
sociaux notamment instagram elle est ce
que l'on appelle une influence euse
active depuis un peu plus de trois ans
sa communauté grandit de jour en jour et
la suite dans son quotidien le milieu de
la décennie que c'est un milieu qui est
assez fermé il n'y a pas énormément
d'emplois donc je me suis dit il faut
pas attendre des diplômés pour aller du
coup chercher de l'emploi autant
partager déjà demandé ce que j'apprends
voilà mon compte instagram donc on avait
les retrouves les trois parties vous
mais la partie du coût recettes
alimentation la partie sport et la
partie du coût lifestyle donc là c'est
les fameux story où je partage voilà le
lifestyle
là que j'étais en train d'aller
travailler là ce que je mange voilà qui
permet du coup aux gens de savoir à peu
près comment je pouvais qui l'aurait
l'alimentation etc c'est plus au niveau
des consultations que je gagne ma vie la
partie du coût rémunération par
publicité instagram sur par exemple une
marque de chaussures une marque de
vêtements que ça c'est quand même un peu
plus compliqué d'avoir de gagner sa vie
foncièrement avec sa points et le les
habits j'espère que vous allez bien
aujourd'hui je vous annonce du coup
qu'on va lancer un f1 q n'hésitez pas à
me poser toutes les questions que vous
avez sur l'alimentation sur le sport sur
le bien-être sur mon parcours sur ce que
je propose en tant qu diététicienne je
cherche à partager du coup la notion que
la diététique la nutrition la bonne
alimentation alimentation saine c'est
pas aussi compliqué que ça en a l'air et
justement normaliser les choses est
passé du coup par ces réseaux sociaux
c'est déjà une première porte avant tout
ce qui est les journaux la télévision et
c'est un second métier qui n'a pas que
des avantages
c'est quand même du travail c'est à dire
qu'on doit être c'est régulier en doit
poster régulièrement que ce soit du coup
les postent des vidéos les stories donc
c'est un travail de tous les jours c'est
à dire que même si on part en vacances
on pense à ce qu'on va poster et obtient
prendre un café bastien promo en photo
donc c'est vrai que c'est une partie du
coup s'il dans notre quotidien quoi
avant de trois ans cette double
casquette profite pleinement à nina ses
patients et ceux qui la suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux elle compte bien
développer encore plus ses deux
activités complémentaires dans les
années à venir
[Musique]